au parti socialiste c'est le silence
radio chez michel rocard un silence qui
contraste en quelque sorte avec le
bourdonnement progressif des
responsables et des militants il demande
après l'échec d'hier soir une vaste
remise en question des idées et les
hommes guilaine chenu claude baril
cela s'appelle une défaite ce n'est pas
la première rue de solférino on a même
fini par s'habituer à ces soirées d
enchanter alors on les fait courte et si
possible silencieuse
après la dérision les questions et l'on
médite le paradoxe de la soirée la
gauche s'élargit et c'est le ps qui
rétrécit d'accord le sont maintenant
c'est qu'il faut savoir se rassembler le
faut absolument parce que sur cette
lancée là on va dans le mur et personnes
de gauche ne sera au deuxième tour de la
présidentielle
michel rocard le premier veut tirer les
leçons de son score et de sa campagne ce
sera sa seule déclaration les français
viennent de nous dire clairement que
nous n'avions pas parlé assez fort qu'il
ne nous sentait pas assez proche d'eux
j'en prends acte
michel rocard avait lui-même fixé la
barre à 18% à 14.5 il sait que la
présidentielle s'éloigne au ps pour le
moment on ne voit surgir ni les couteaux
ni les poisons pas plus que les hommes
providentiels
on ne fait que condamné michel rocard
aux changements a plus ni moins il
faudrait qu'ils se surpassent il faut
qu'ils demandent que la force et en lui
qu'il a la capacité d'affronter une
élection présidentielle le peso rester
unis on doit éviter les règlements de
comptes et surtout ne doit plus parler
des élections présidentielles nous avons
besoin de six mois de trêve
six mois c'est le temps donné à michel
rocard pour se reprendre et concrétiser
sa nouvelle alliance six mois c'est
également le temps qu'il reste à jacques
delors à la tête de la commission
européenne une conjonction de dates qui
pour le moment n'est qu'un hasard